you are someone who looks very much at
future of the media how it can be solved
also kind of working within cnn
what's that like
well i certainly went through this media
ringer and i appreciate you and crystal
um and folks like joe and sam harris
and so many others breakfast club that
had me on when i was
not as mainstream i suppose and just
heard me out
and talked about my
campaign uh now being on cnn
like i have more insight into the goods
and bads of how the media works
uh and i've been honest saying
look for me being on cnn i think is very
positive because it helps
just get my face and voice in front of
uh americans in a way that can help
advance our
goals and ideas and i will say being on
cnn
i have never gotten any notes
in terms of hey um maybe you should try
and make this point or
feedback being like hey that point was
not great
or go down this direction so
you know on that level um it's quite
positive but i also see that there are
incentives wrapped up in the medium that
end up driving coverage in particular
ways
and that the medium doesn't allow for
particular
types of conversations or ideas to get
out that might
not fit into the rhythm of a five-minute
cable news hit that in those news hits
comprise the vast majority
of the coverage because the thought is
that well if you're a tv audience like
you need to keep things snappy and then
kind of get in and out and
you have like graphic and video and some
other stuff
so i i let's just say that you know
being part of the media
is just fueling my desire to try to
uh change the incentives in ways that'll
make it work better for
more americans and i i say this
in particular about the thousand plus
local newspapers that went out of
business so are there issues with cable
news yes
major issues uh but at least they exist
you know if you have no local paper it's
very hard
uh to vote on what's going on in your
town
uh and so what's going on in media is a
is a microcosm of what
is going wrong in american life which is
just the market
runs everything and so if you're like
post office doesn't make money
[ __ ] the post office you know like uh
that local paper didn't make money
anymore
get rid of it it's like well maybe that
local paper actually had some value to
the people of that town
beyond the fact that it made money as a
private
concern to me we have to fix democracy
and
and it's going to be difficult to fix
democracy if you don't have
uh certain types of functioning media
organizations yeah and
let's talk about the incentives there
because we've talked a lot here on you
know on my podcast just about the way
that the media business is changing you
know you have
first you had the click ad revenue model
of course there was a monopoly on
classified ads
now that's gone with facebook google and
so much more i actually
use a line all the time that you think
you said on my show which is that the
internet naturally sex
selects for monopolies like nobody wants
to use the fourth worst google
the second best facebook or whatever but
it so if we're gonna live within that
system with realities and i've always
appreciated that you're fair
right that you know people actually
people don't really want to use multiple
facebooks or multiple googles
if we're going to use if we're going to
live in that world what do we do with
media so because how do we actually make
it so because you don't want
government subsidized local news either
i mean that you know we're talking about
earmarks and pork
like i actually do want and this is
where we disagree i do want i think
that's subsidized local news
yeah but how would you protect it um how
would you protect it
from you know legislators who are using
it as a bargaining chip like if you look
at what's happening right now with voice
of america
and the global news um agency there have
been all these accusations like oh trump
put in this person
and you know even though this person has
been selected by congress so
if we were going to fund it like what
are the ways that we could do it
while keeping it independent with the
essential role that media has
and then also protecting it from
political influence is it even possible
i think it is possible and i think that
there are
a few different parties that need to be
part of it
number one is government number two is
non-profits and ngos and then number
three are the
the media companies and i think there's
a way you can fund it where let's say
hypothetically you said
guess what getting quality
information about what's going on in
your community is a public good
and we're just going to say that there's
a certain amount of money that gets
allocated
for every congressional district based
on population
and there's going to be like a local
paper that ends up being the beneficiary
of this
or like a local station or whatever like
the local organs are
and it could be public private uh you
know it could even be in some cases
philanthropic
uh but that there are different
approaches these media organizations
could 100 exist if they weren't forced
to throw off
market level profits every given quarter
so what do i mean by that it's like look
my local paper can't compete
but if you had a combination public
private
and you had a paper that made a certain
amount of money and then spent that much
money on coverage
and it broke even every year obviously
no one would invest in that
because you know it's a terrible
business but
uh as the public would you invest in
that probably i mean you'd
you know you'd put it in place and then
at least you don't have to necessarily
and in my mind it would be worth the
subsidy i have no problem with
subsidizing
uh local journalism and i also think
sagar this is a fundamental issue
um and this is where i possibly and i
think i'm clear-headed about this
genuinely
this is probably where you and i
disagree conservatives look up and say
hey you can't have government involved
with local media because it'll become
politicized in a bargaining chip
uh and they might influence coverage et
cetera et cetera
and then i look at it and say okay
the current situation is literally zero
like can you
improve on zero and if you have
issues around politicization and the
rest of it you can look around the world
and say
look are there independent media
organizations that are publicly funded
that seem like they're okay criticizing
the government and you would find yes
they do exist
you know you could hold up the bbc as
one potential example and say that
is it perfect no but does it exist and a
lot of people
get value from it and like does it seem
fairly independent journalistically and
able to
critique leaders yeah sure uh
and so the the the correct approach is
not in my opinion just throw up your
hands and say can't do it like
government's gonna screw it up somehow
instead you have to get into the weeds
of it and say look
like the current path is leading towards
in this case
total absence of local journalism which
i would argue is very disastrous for it
for democracy
so then you have to just put your hard
hat on and roll up your sleeves and say
okay what are the issues we're concerned
about
you don't want politicians to be able to
yank funding every time that the
the news organization says something
nasty about them well then like
let's see if we can make this funding
mechanism independent
of congress's whims maybe you have like
very long time frames or you can only
make changes like x years in advance
when
like like it might not matter to you
anyway right
uh so like that to me is like a more
uh principled approach um but and this
is the tough truth as someone who and
it's fun because i know some people like
me
because they think i have some
libertarian impulses and leanings and
whatnot
um like i am very conscious of the fact
that there are a lot of things in my
opinion government is terrible at
and you'd rather not have them involved
with it but
there there's also this tough truth that
we're in an era where
you're going to need government at a
minimum to inject resources
into certain types of institutions or to
solve certain types of problems because
there's so many problems we have
that the market will not have any
interest in solving so i actually
completely agree with you and you know
people
you know who know me know that it's not
about the government intervention
necessarily that
i'm most concerned about it's actually
that i'm not
so sure that we don't have a private
sector solution and
the reason i say that is because i look
at somebody like you
who was born like i said with the joe
rogan
of the internet i see this burgeoning
alternative media ecosystem
i see sub stack i see what's happening
in silicon valley
with tech and so much more the explosion
of new businesses and more
and i say you know what there's
something going on here there's a
realignment so to speak right
you have changing business you know
changing media landscape
changing business landscape you're
changing political coalitions it's like
the craziest election in a long maybe
crazier than
the one before that so i kind of apply
it as a framework towards any
everything and that's what i mean when i
say i look at the media
and i know you're involved in the tech
space as well i see this explosion of
subset i see this explosion of
independent journalists
guys like matt taibi joe rogan going to
spotify
the emergence of this whole new culture
and i'm like what what we
what it's really up to is entrepreneurs
and others
is to find a way in order to make that
work for local news and if that actually
cannot work
we truly cannot work i'm not above the
public solution
whatsoever it's more about jumping
towards that
a little bit too quickly if that makes
it it can't work brother
you know the numbers guy has looked at
and said this is a total disaster
and when when companies have invested
tens of millions in it you remember
patch yeah you know like it was just
setting money on fire
um the local papers have all become
you know desiccated husks or disappeared
and i walked through those offices
because i was campaigning in rural iowa
and new hampshire and elsewhere and so
you go interview with a local paper
and guess what that office looks like
now it's half empty and you know people
are looking around wondering if they're
going to survive
and that's pre pandemic i mean post
pandemic the stuff's even worse
you know can you imagine being like a
free weekly in austin or
boston or wherever trying to survive now
i mean it doesn't make any sense like
the the
the you i am um
i'm sure that there is no uh
entrepreneurial market-based solution
um for local journalism unless you were
to have something like universal basic
income where people
had the their needs met and then if they
wanted to they could write about stuff
but even then you would have certain
types of journalism that were not
included in that
because like a local blog is not the
same as
having sure a genuine news organization
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode